pub
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
14 juillet fête nationale dans le
roulement des chars et le bruit des
fanfares en face de ces onze mille
hommes qui défilaient en masse régulière
devant le général de gaulle et les plus
hautes personnalités du pays
une question s'est posée dans les
esprits et dans les coeurs ce 14 juillet
sera-t-il le dernier de cette période
tumultueuse dans laquelle vit la france
depuis 20 ans on peut en tout cas
affirmé
les discours du général de gaulle en
normandie et l'accueil qu'ils ont reçu
en témoignent que la france n'est pas
renié rien pour que la paix réelle
reviennent pour qu'il soit mis fin
d'abord à cette guerre civile
d'outre-méditerranée absurde puisque les
deux parties acceptent le même principe
de l'autodétermination
le 14 juillet 61 sera-t-il une fête
nationale enfin pacifique dans un monde
réconcilié
[Musique]
du sang dans la politique japonaise
moins d'une heure après la désignation
de son successeur à la tête de son parti
l'ex-premier ministre monsieur kishi a
été frappé de six coups de poignard bien
que l'hémorragie était importante
l'état de monsieur ki finn mais pas ses
jours en danger l'agresseur un fanatique
d'extrême droite et un de ces vétérans
de l'armée impériale qui ne se sont
jamais consoler de la défaite nippone
mais on comprend mal à quoi correspond
son geste
est ce un épilogue au drame de lurs qui
fit couler tant d'encre après sept ans
passés en prison à la suite de sa
condamnation
gaston dominici gracié a été ramenée par
son fils gustave à la ferme de la grande
terre il y a retrouvé sa femme la
sardine entre les murs qui furent le
décor du drame affreux qui coûta la vie
à la famille drummond le vieillard qui
signa des aveux formelle dénis
aujourd'hui toute participation au
meurtre
mais le jour de son retour des mains
anonymes ont fleuri au cimetière de
forcalquier les tombe du père de la mère
et de l'enfant assassiné
[Musique]
qui serait désigné comme candidat du
parti démocrate à la présidence des
états unis à damas et stevenson
candidats déjà deux fois malheureux que
ses supporters présentait une troisième
fois
john kennedy qui malgré son double
handicap sa jeunesse il a 43 ans et sa
religion des catholiques étaient
désignés comme pouvant réunir une large
majorité dans le parti est en dernière
ligne
le sénateur du texas lyndon johnson dont
les chances étaient bien moindres que
celles des deux premiers
entre lesquels la lutte devait être
chaud en dépit de l'appui apporté par la
brousse welt à stevenson 845 voix sont
allées à john kennedy
c'est à dire une très large majorité et
le jeune candidat devenu aujourd'hui le
porte drapeau officiel du parti
démocrate va préparer maintenant la
grande bataille qui va l'opposer au
leader républicain c'est-à-dire au vice
président nixon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est dans l'émeute et le sens que se
sont déroulées les premières heures de
la nouvelle république congolaise né de
l'ex congo belge léopoldville reste
encore vides et muette prostré dans la
stupeur et l'effondrement après les
violences des derniers jours magasins
les vastes et immeubles incendiés
automobile brûlé c'est le décor sinistre
de la capitale à l'heure de
l'indépendance
aussi les européens qui restent on
demandait des armes on leur en a donné
les familles vont choisir dans ces
dépôts disparates
de quoi tenir tête
mais la plupart s'efforce de partir
on les voit avec leurs valises empilés
abandonné souvent leur voiture à
l'embarcadère pour passer de l'autre
côté à brazzaville ou drapeaux français
et congolais flotter côte à côte
[Musique]
depuis l'émeute tragique c'est par
milliers que les européens de
léopoldville dépouillé et parfois
blessés ont cherché refuge dans l'ex
congo français où le président de la
jeune république
l'abbé fulbert youlou est venu au
débarcadère de brazzaville leur apporter
ses encouragements
un camp d'urgence a recueilli tous ces
pauvres gens ou les premiers secours
leur ont été donnés jusqu'à présent près
de 4000 personnes ont pu passer le
fleuve est trouvé ici un abri dans cette
circonstance dramatique
la jeune république du congo et son
président l'abbé fulbert youlou ont
manifesté un souci de solidarité qui les
place à l'ordre du jour de l'humanité
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les avions belges continuent également à
transporter à bruxelles des groupes
d'européens bruxelles leur a fait un
accueil douloureusement ému mais cette
émotion nationale n'est pas restée
inactive les mêmes avions qui a mené les
sinistrés remmener leur plein cargaison
de troupes précaution qui empêcherait
peut-être de nouveaux désordres sanglant
mais n'efface pas les deuils d'hier et à
ces deuils la belgique mais les sa
colère une manifestation d'anciens
coloniaux aller dans les rues de
bruxelles en donné l'illustration
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'ol lui était saisi de la question le
délégué belle je devais devant
l'assemblée évoqué dans leur tragique
nudité les dramatiques journée de la
jeune république et je tiens à le
souligner ne songe à remettre en cause
l'indépendance du congo ni la validité
de la recommandation formulée par ce
conseil il ya une semaine à peine les
assurances les plus formelles ont
d'ailleurs été donnée à ce sujet par le
gouvernement de bruxelles où chacun de
nous la queue désir celui des vestes je
n'ai pas à développer chez lui l'ordre
la paix et la prospérité dans
léopoldville bouleversé par la révolte
la gendarmerie restait la seule force
congolaise devant l'armée mutinés elle
avait rétabli le calme
un calme relatif sans doute mais les
mutins occupé toujours l'aérodrome
coupant toute communication avec
l'extérieur
ce fut donc aux troupes belges de
libérer l'aérodrome et les quelques
centaines de civils près au départ qui
s'y étaient entassés et qui se trouvait
à la merci des émeutiers
c'est dans le sifflement des balles que
les réfugiés de l'aérodrome sur le
sentiment de leur délivrance
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'opération fut rapidement menée parmi
les blessés quelques civils atteints
pendant l'attaqué
quelques soldats congolais fait
prisonnier devait être libéré par le
commandement belge après une
intervention de monsieur millon m'bow
ministre sans doute trop libérales comme
monsieur lumumba devait démissionner
depuis des renforts belge atterrissait
l'aérodrome étaient occupés et le trafic
aérien pouvait reprendre
[Applaudissements]
mais
[Musique]
qu'allait-il se passait à léopoldville
les forces rebelles se décide à y
rentrer en vue de maintenir l'ordre
parmi une population à l'esprit
surchauffée et pour être peut-être à de
nouveaux excès
[Musique]
eq c'est que l'intervention même du
ministre affaires étrangères monsieur
bomboko n'était pas toujours susceptible
de contenir léopoldville était un baril
de poudre ou la moindre étincelle
pouvait déclencher une nouvelle
catastrophe
ainsi la découverte du cadavre d'un boy
faillit bien malgré les objurgations des
autorités tourné au drame et déchaîné de
nouvelle fureur
[Musique]
c'est dans ces circonstances que l'onu
décidé d'intervenir
les troupes du ghana commandée par le
général alexander arriver les premières
pour rétablir l'ordre
[Musique]
ouais
avec les troupes du ghana des troupes
tunisienne prenait immédiatement
position à léopoldville à la place des
soldats belges
[Musique]
la situation en est là mais le chant
reste ouvert que sera demain l'ex congo
belge
[Musique]